-This is very exciting.
I know you were back at "SNL
when Eddie Murphy hosted
in December.
That must have been
an incredible night.
-Yo, man. Eddie is one
of my comedic heroes --
probably the top comedic her
in my life.
To be a part of that monologue
was awesome.
That's awesome.
That's working with Eddie.
Imagine that,
being on the stage with him.
That was awesome.
-And then in August,
"Coming 2 America 2" is coming
and you got to do that with him.
What was that like?
-That's Eddie, man.
It was magic.
To watch him and Arsenio d
their thing, those are my O.G.s.
Dope. Great.
-Speaking of "O.G.,"
Season 3 premiering on TBS
Congratulations.
That's quite an accomplishment
-Come on. Tuesday night.
Yeah, Tuesday, 10:30, TBS.
Yo, Seth, I want you
to come on our show, man.
-It's three seasons.
You haven't asked me yet.
-Yeah, Season 4, you're going to
play my parole officer.
-Oh, I would like that a lot
-You fit that.
You fit like a parole officer.
I'm gonna take you out of
character,
but you're a dirty cop.
I'll have you play a dirty cop
You gonna win an Oscar lik
Denzel did in "Training Day.
Who would love to see
Seth Meyers play a dirty cop
I want you to do a dirty cop
-Thank you.
-You sniff cocaine off you
dashboard of your squad car.
Santa Claus this Christmas
is gonna come down the chimney
wearing a hospital mask.
He gonna go, "Ho, ho, ho, ho."
We know it was you,
mother [bleep]
Your beard is sticking out
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think you --
-"Just give us the toys,
you [bleep] prick."
[ Laughter ]
-Tracy --
-Yo, I can't take
this social distancing.
I went to hug my own mother,
and she gave me her elbow.
-Yeah, have you
been outside at all?
Have you gone outside at all
-Oh, you know pregnant women
got to breastfeed from
a distance with their kids
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Pregnant mothers
got to breastfeed their kids
with a slingshot.
[ Laughter ]
From 6 feet away.
-[ Laughs ]
-Their mouth like, "Wah."
That milk hit they mouth.
[ Blubbers ]
-You know what
the funny thing is?
I actually think we're getting
exactly as much medical
information from you
as we are from the presidentia
press conferences.
-Yo, I'm gonna keep my hea
where it should be.
-Have you gone outside,
Tracy, at all?
Have you gone outside?
-Have I gone outside?
Absolutely.
-What have you done?
-What have I done?
I peed on the corner
like I usually do.
I had to pee. I got out my car
and took a piss
on the side of the building.
-Are there things
that you're most upset
have been canceled or closed
What's been the most -
-Yes, the strip clubs, man
-Yeah.
-I never thought
I'd see the day.
Remember when me and you used to
go to strip clubs all the time
They closed it down.
-They did?
-Yeah, you got to go through
a drive-through now.
-Oh, what happens
at the drive-through?
-They shake their [bleep]
like this, in the drive-through.
[ Laughs ]
-Hey, are you using this time --
I know you're a cinephile.
You --
-Yo, Seth, you want to see
a young girl in Cancun?
Look.
[ Both laugh ]
-I have been meaning to ask.
Have you been watching
any new films,
any new television shows?
-I watched "The Tiger King."
-Oh, did you like it?
-That's my family.
[ Laughter ]
-That's your family?
-Yeah, I'm related
to him, to Joe.
-You're related to Joe Exotic?
-Yeah, I'm related to him.
-How so?
-That's my uncle.
-Oh, he's your uncle.
-Yeah, his husband,
the one with the meth teeth?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yo, I met a girl like that.
Her eyes looked so pretty.
-Uh-huh.
-Took her mask off,
she look like Leon Spinks.
-[ Laughs ]
-You wanted comedy?
I'm giving it to you.
-J.B. Smoove?
-If I'm in the supermarket
and you can smell my fart,
you standing too close to me
You not 6 feet behind me.
-Oh, is that --
-That's a fart.
That's fart range,
especially after you ate
pork and beans and franks.
A can of Campbell's Pork and
Beans, that's school lunch
That's true grit.
-It's been such a delight
talking to you
through these trying times
I do think --
-Yo, I got cabin fever.
You can't be mad at me, man.
-I'm not mad at you.
-I've been in this [bleep] house
for four weeks, God damn it,
with these [bleep] kids.
-[ Laughs ]
How are the kids behaving?
-How they behaving?
-Yeah.
-Boy, they downstairs in
the cage right now, God damn it.
Lock these mother [bleep] up
-[ Laughs ]
-I got to lock
these mother [bleep] up, man
-You got to let them --
-[Bleep]
-You got to let them
out of the cage!
-I had to lock these mother --
One of them tried
to drop a bowling ball on
my [bleep] head the other night.
-[ Laughs ]
-They trying to kill me
in here, Seth.
-Oh, Tracy, I'm so glad
you're persevering
through these trying times
I can't believe your childre
would do that to you.
You're such a wonderful father
You provide for them,
and they're trying to drop
a bowling ball on your head?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good kids, good kids. Good
Home-schooling, they said,
"Look, Daddy, I did math."
I say, "Yeah, good, good, good
[bleep] good, good.
Yeah.
Good, kid. Good.
Yeah, yeah.
Good, kid. Good, kid."
-Tracy, every time
I talk to you,
I forget all the troubles
in the world.
Today is no exception.
-I'm praying
for everybody's happiness,
and let's get past this,
'cause, yo, Seth,
this is temporary.
God is -- God is forever.
-I'll see you on the other side,
my friend, alright?
-Love you, Seth.
-I love you, Tracy.
Everyone, give it up
for Tracy Morgan.